i'm just told that practice will happen
tonight for the baltimore ravens they
will have their walk through even though
the game has been postponed from tuesday
to wednesday that capped a fairly active
hour of information that i was getting
about critical mass that was arriving
for the ravens and the steelers what i
had been told by a very good source
connected to the union as opposed to my
usual not very good sources but that
never stops me is that there was fear
that ravens players would say
we
aren't playing
period we refuse to play and that would
constitute technically a wildcat strike
now every collective bargaining
agreement has a provision that says
there shall be no lock out no strike
during the term of the deal it's only
after the deal expires that it becomes
legal for management to lock out the
workforce or the workforce to go on
strike but under certain circumstances
and i don't want this to turn into
continuing legal education for anyone
out there who needs a labor law credit
under certain circumstances
the workforce can say
we're not working and usually in a
industrial setting it arises when
there's some sort of a safety issue and
shireen there's a safety issue here in
the minds of the players because they
look at
not being able to gather not being able
to practice not being able to prepare
as a potential safety risk for them when
it's time to play the steelers
especially when you're calling up all
these guys that don't have a lot of
experience who are being thrust into
a new role peter king pointed out that
the guy who's playing center for the
ravens and i don't even remember who the
guy is i mean he's gonna be nose-to-nose
with cam hayward for crying out loud and
the guy's never played center in the nfl
before that's the kind of physical risk
you're getting into so the ravens said
we may not play the ravens players said
we may not play and it looks like the
nfl blinked and said okay we'll move the
game to wednesday and give you a chance
to prepare between monday and tuesday
sort of seems like a hail mary for the
nfl right here mike that they had to do
this they had to give the ravens more
time even though i'm sure that's not
what they wanted to do they wanted to
play this game and
in some respects i'm sure they feel like
they're giving baltimore a little bit
more of an advantage than they should
have i don't think they are baltimore's
still going to be short-handed and if i
i'm rg iii i am scared as you said of my
physical health going into this game
because with that offensive line and the
lack of offensive lineman that he's
going to have starting offensive lineman
his health would seem to be in grave
danger going into this game against this
defense and you know i'm sure the
broncos are sitting here today too right
now probably thinking why didn't we
think of this yesterday and refused to
play yesterday not quite the same
circumstances but it was in the sense
that they had no chance in that game
yesterday just as i think i don't care
how far down the line you move this game
unless you move to week 18
nobody's giving the ravens a chance to
win this game mike with with all the
guys they still have on the coveted list
this is high stakes poker for the
players to engage in and in hindsight
maybe the broncos players should have
risen up and said we aren't going to
play in this game with no quarterbacks
now what did happen was broncos
management from ceo joe ellis to gm john
elway to coach vic fangio lobbied the
nfl aggressively to bump the game back
i'm told until today because technically
they could have gotten the three
quarterbacks who weren't positive for
covet 19 back today drew lock brett
ripon and blake bortles the league said
no we're not doing that we don't
postpone games for competitive reasons
okay fine but if the players had said
we're just not going to play that's what
would have raised the stakes here and
who knows what the league would have
said because
if you're the players what you're doing
is you're going all in with your game
check because the broncos players got
paid for sunday by playing if you refuse
to play and the game would get cancelled
then you don't get paid pursuant to the
agreement that was struck back in august
between the league and the union and the
other problem is this and and this is
what has the nfl players association
concerned i'm told
if there would be a wildcat strike that
would
violate the terms of the agreement that
was struck back in august to allow the
season to go forward there is concern
that the league would say fine we're
going to rip up the entire agreement
we're going to pull the plug on the
season because we are swimming in red
ink here and this is our exit ramp this
is our easy way out this is our path to
stop the bleeding see you later rest of
season that would be an extreme example
but
the union in order to be prudent in
protecting the interests of all of its
constituents needs to at least be
concerned about that possibility so
hasn't happened yet
isn't happening as it relates to the
ravens because they got the game bumped
today and presumably now the ravens
players will stand down and get ready
for the game but there's a way these
dominoes just careen out of control
and you end up with
possibly the season being thrown in the
wastebasket although i i i'd be stunned
if that happens although let's rewind to
january 1 and
go through the events of 2020 and how
stunned would you be if you knew back at
the turn of the year what we were in for
so you can't rule anything out at this
point
it's crazy mike i was just thinking
about that all the things we're talking
about today who would have dreamed you
know a few weeks ago even in the midst
of all this that we'd be talking about
what we're talking about today it's just
incredible this whole year this whole
season everything's just been incredible
and crazy and you know we were texting
on saturday and i i texted to you guys
that i felt like this was a house of
cards and it really felt like it was
about to come down for the nfl between
the the 49ers situation with being
kicked out of their stadium in their
practice facility and then with the
ravens all their positives with the
broncos not having a quarterback it just
seemed like all the build up for the
entire season has come down to this and
league has been in in my view anyway
lucky to get to the point now where they
have not had a game postponed to week 18
but it's really looking like we are
close to either hitting the pause button
or moving to that week 18 as things
continue to develop it's just been a
wild few days
yeah and and the week 18 scenario
and like so many other things that
relates to this season shireen it has to
come into full focus to truly understand
what the potential issues would be and i
was playing this out today okay raven
steelers it goes to week 18. it becomes
the first game that moves to week 18.
every raven steelers game after that is
operating on a tightrope without a net
because if the ravens have an issue if
the steelers have an issue if any of
their opponents have issues and that
game has to be postponed
wait wait a minute you how where do you
postpone it to week 18 is already spoken
for as it relates to the ravens and the
steelers what if steelers bills can't be
played in two weeks because of a covet
issue with either pittsburgh or buffalo
and we don't know what's going to happen
once the dust settles on the post
thanksgiving
spread on top of the spread
what if that game can't be played what
if that's where we're headed so how do
you pick and choose how do you
prioritize if you're the league do you
say well all right the first one we
postponed was raven steelers so that's
the one that gets played week 18 even
though steelers bills once we play all
the other games may have more relevance
to more teams and may be a
bigger game and also would be a more
compelling game to the extent that we're
trying to make back some money and we
want to broadcast some games in national
windows steelers bills better game raven
steelers raven stink or at least they're
currently in the midst of stink who
knows where the b week 18 i think
whatever would happen shireen if if
games get postponed to a week 18 i think
the league would end up just postponing
indefinitely with no commitment that
that's the game that'll be played week
18 because you don't want to paint
yourself into a corner because there
could be a more important game involving
one of those two teams that you would
rather play in week 18.
yeah and it makes perfect sense mike and
i think you've called it the nuclear
option for the nfl which is what it
seems like that is the the worst case
scenario for them they don't want to do
that we know that they want to try to
get all these games in which is why now
they're gonna jam this game in you're
gonna have a game on wednesday and
you're obviously gonna have to move back
that steelers game that was set for
sunday you have to move that one back to
monday or tuesday of next week so now
suddenly the steelers are playing all
these games in here forget the mini buy
they were supposed to have they're going
to have a bunch of games here in a row
just as the ravens are if they can get
these games in but that's the hope that
now that they can play this game on
wednesday and we don't have to have that
postponement that we're talking about
and i agree with you you don't want to
do it because you don't know what's
going to happen down the line this might
it's getting worse by the week it's
getting worse out in the communities and
now we've seen it getting worse within
teams of patriots just today put julian
edelman on the covet list every day
we're starting to see guys go on here
big name guys are going on and you see
what happened with the broncos with no
quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports